quitté la politique pour le privé dans
le jargon on appelle ça le pantouflage
une pratique vieille comme la vème
république
mais qui s'est décomplexé avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir des manuels macron une
quarantaine de responsables de
l'exécutif ont quitté leurs fonctions
gouvernementales pour voir si l'herbe
est plus verte ailleurs
la dernière en date brune poirson ancien
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique non reconduite dans ses
fonctions après l'arrivée de jean castex
elle s'en est retourné à son siège de
député du vaucluse à l'assemblée
nationale où il n'a fait que cinq
petites apparitions alors qu'elle avait
été élu pour cinq ans le 15 avril
dernier elle officialise son départ pour
une multinationale accord premier groupe
hôtelier d'europe
je suis très heureuse de rejoindre l'un
des leaders mondiaux de l'hospitalité et
de pouvoir ainsi mettre mon expérience
et mes convictions au service de
l'action dans ses nouvelles fonctions
je souhaite contribuer à poursuivre
l'ambition de accor depuis sa création
fait revivre une hospitalité positive
moderne et responsable
de là à parler de conflit d'intérêts
s'il n'y a qu'un pas quitté la politique
pour vendre son carnet d'adressés au
groupe accor avant la fin de son mandat
parlementaire
on connaissait le pantouflage des hauts
fonctionnaires mais les maquereaux nice
repousse les limites de l'indécence
chapeau brune poirson ce tourniquet du
public au privé c'est un recyclage qui
existe depuis des années et qui touche
les élus de tous bords
dans le cas de brune poirson il y a
manifestement un conflit d'intérêt au vu
des fonction qu'elle va occuper une
pantoufle ça ne sert pas qu'à marcher et
ça à la république en marche on l'a bien
compris brune poirson est loin d'être la
seule proche des manuels macron à
pratiquer l'art du pantouflage
on retrouve par exemple si bête ndiaye
ancien porte parole du gouvernement et
qui s'est vu offrir le poste de
secrétaire général du groupe adecco
france
ismaël et meulien ancien conseiller
spécial d'emmanuel macro à lui été
engagé par le g
du luxe lvmh sylvain fort ancien
directeur de la communication de
l'elysée est aujourd'hui directeur
général de la collection d'art pineau
collection rien de bien étonnant quand
on sait déjà qu emmanuel macron
autrefois inspecteur des finances a
travaillé pour rothschild ou encore qu'
edouard philippe
à l'époque membre du conseil d'état a
fait du lobbying pour areva
c'est un banquier d'affaires qui m'a
alerté sur le fait que les pantouflages
est c'est à dire les trajets entre
public et privé s'étaient accélérées
depuis l'élection de macron ils se sont
lâchés ça dépasse les bornes
je me suis dit qu'il était en train de
se passer quelque chose est de fait
dix-huit mois après la nomination du
premier gouvernement philippe 40
conseillers ministériels avaient déjà
pantoufles et c'est énorme
l'un des sens n'est pas que des
responsables publics par dans le privé
mais qu'il s'occupe des affaires
publiques et du lobbying pour le compte
de ces entreprises en monnayant leur
connaissance de l'état au lieu de
travailler à la création de richesse si
ses anciens responsables politiques
n'ont pas été inquiétés d'autres se sont
vu retoquer par la commission de
déontologie de la fonction publique
encadrée par l'article 432-13 du code
pénal relatif aux délits de prise
illégale d'intérêt la pratique peut être
condamnée si elle ne respecte pas
l'expiration d'un délai de trois ans
suivant la cessation des fonctions
exécutif a récemment l'ancien conseiller
sanitaire d'olivier vers ans grégory
hémeury s'est vu empêcher de rejoindre
le groupe gériatrique courrian au motif
que ses fonctions pourrait créer un
conflit d'intérêts et favoriser
l'entreprise en l'informant des
décisions gouvernementales
bernard soir chimie ancien directeur
central du renseignement intérieur
reconverti en consultant indépendant est
quant à lui accusé d'avoir mis à profit
ses méthodes d'espionnage pour le compte
de son client lvmh de rares exemples qui
ne dissuade pas pour autant certain de
porter la pantoufle mieux qu un soulier
d'or